6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Pippa. In this programme we're talking about happiness. So what makes you happy, Neil?
Oh, it makes me happy when I'm with a group of old friends and we're having a good laugh.
How about you, Pippa?
Cats make me very happy, especially if I see a cat on the street that I don't know and it lets me
give it a little stroke that always makes me happy.
I'm not surprised. That sounds great.
So, happiness means different things to different people, but what's for sure is that most people
would like to be happy. And the small Himalayan Kingdom of Bhutan has taken this to a new level
with the idea of gross national happiness or GNH.
We'll be hearing more about gross national happiness and learning some useful new vocabulary soon.
But first Pippa, I have a question for you. Of course, it's not just the people of Bhutan who
want to be happy. In fact, the United Nations has even announced an international day of happiness.
But when is that? Is international happiness day A the 20th of March B the 20th of June or C the 20th
of November? I'm going to say the 20th of June because it would be sunny in the UK.
Okay, let's find out if you're right at the end of the programme.
Now, briefly, gross national happiness means preserving Bhutan's natural environment and culture
through sustainable and eco-friendly development. Bhutan's government sees these goals
as more important than growing the economy at any cost.
For many years Bhutan was closed to the outside world. The first foreign tourists arrived
in 1974 and television was only introduced in 1999. The King of Bhutan wanted to modernise the
country and give it the benefits of modern technology but without damaging traditional culture.
So he invited outside experts to develop the idea of gross national happiness.
One expert was Dr. Harvinto speaking here to Charmaine Cosia, presenter of BBC World Service
programme The Inquiry. So his idea was how could we modernise and open our country without losing
its culture, its environment and its very strong social fabric because Bhutan was one of the
only countries in Asia who has never colonised therefore its culture is very intact and vibrant,
mainly Buddhist culture. And so the idea was that gross national happiness should be the focus
on all governmental decisions and policies. So the well-being and happiness of citizens
took them to stage Bhutan has a strong social fabric meaning there are good
relationships within communities and these hold society together. Unlike other Asian countries,
Bhutan was never colonised so its Buddhist culture and traditions are intact,
they're complete and unspoiled. As a result the happiness of Bhutan's people
took centre stage it became the most important thing. Bhutan's emphasis on happiness has been
admired around the world but there have been problems too. One is the migration of Bhutanese workers
to India and other countries in search of better paid jobs and opportunities, something known as
the brain drain. So in 2023 the King of Bhutan announced a multi-million dollar project called
the Mindfulness City, a new Himalayan city built on spiritual and environmental principles
all powered by renewable energy. Originally from Bhutan, Dr. Laoang Uguel is the
project's director and spoke with Charme Enkosia for the BBC World Services, the Inquiry.
The project is also about reversing Bhutan's brain drain. The intention is to have locals
run this whole Mindfulness City so in that sense it's also to attract the migrants that have left
and in the process of having worked abroad gain the extra skills come back to the Mindfulness City
and work. As well as being a futuristic eco city, the Mindfulness City hopes to stop Bhutan's
brain drain by attracting workers back home to Bhutan. These local workers can then use the extra
skills that they've learned abroad through upskilling and upskilling is the process where
worker skills are improved through training. The idea of gross national happiness might sound
unusual but it's interesting to see Bhutan balancing economic growth with the happiness of its
people. Yes that's true and it reminds me of your question now. Yes I asked you what the date
of International Happiness Day is. I said it was the 20th of June in the summer in the UK.
Well maybe it's better for people in the Southern Hemisphere because it's actually the 20th of
March. Ah nice. And if you got that answer right why not try our interactive quiz which you'll
find on our website bbclearningenglish.com. Okay let's recap the vocabulary we've learned
starting with modernise to make something more modern for example through introducing technology.
Our country's social fabric means the relationships which connect a community together.
The adjective intact means complete and undamaged. If something takes center stage it becomes
more important than anything else. A brain drain happens when large numbers of educated and skilled
people leave their own country to live and work in another country where they can earn more money.
And finally up-skilling means improving worker skills through training and experience.
Once again our six minutes are up goodbye for now. Goodbye.